full disclosure this is mamrie Hart's
hat I found it in our house this doesn't
make my hair look better I think it
draws attention to the idea that I think
it doesn't look good I'm doing really
movie director cosplay this is Deb
that's not I'm the director son now Hey
hi my name is grace Helbig if you don't
know now you know your life is different
now I went on Twitter a while ago and I
asked you guys what kind of videos you
wanted to see and a lot of you said you
wanted to see stream-of-consciousness
video which always surprises me because
it's just me blabbing blabbing about
blab all you could see there's a wide
variety of seating options but I'm
sitting on the floor so you're just
dream consciousness video if you're new
to this concept it's exactly what it
sounds like it's just me babbling about
blab well I have gone full vacation dad
anyone need a dad that's on vacation I'm
your girl we have a pool that you can
swim in at this place which is amazing
but last night I was swimming in and
then they were better that were flying
in the sky and they kept diving towards
the pool I was very scared because my
dad told me when I was younger we went
to a playground a couple times with my
brothers bats would come out at night at
this particular playground and he was
like be careful because bats swooped
down to try and get hair to build their
nests and that stuck with me dad I know
you're an avid watcher of the vlogs when
my stepmom has them on in front of you I
don't know if you know that that's stuck
with me for the rest of my life I'm
still terrified of bat so that happened
the other night which was fun also I
don't talk about this much on my videos
but I probably should I have a podcast
if you don't know called me actually and
we've had some really amazing guests on
recently Nick your dad has been on it
well over at Caspar Lee doctor cold
grits in Makati all these amazing people
and so many more
okay previous Grace's future grace
interjecting because I have an important
thing to add what are the other major
guests that we just had on an episode
the podcast that will come up this
Halloween is the gallery show she's been
on the podcast for the last three years
on our Halloween episode because that
girl attracts go
in a variety of ways you'll hear all
about it but this is also relevant
because when I'm trying my best Gabbie
show cosplay right now sorry this is as
best as I can do - she is releasing her
first book called adult lessons and you
guys know I work with audible all the
time so this is very fitting as of
yesterday the 19th adult lessons the
gabbie show yogi Hanna's new book is
available on audible as an audiobook
that you can download for free using my
custom audible link only about calm sash
grace if you don't already know what you
probably should buy at this point but
who am I to judge what you were chained
in your brain audible is a website that
you can download audiobooks and listen
to them at your convenience and I can
attest that I love this website one
because I'm biased both of my books
graces guide and grace and style are
available in audio version on audible
until because I driving my car a lot and
listening for an audiobook is way easier
for me than reading sometimes you can
browse books by category you can browse
by author or title it makes it super
super easy and gabi job there's a lot
off the book on the upcoming podcast it
made me really excited I thought this
would be a great way for you guys to get
excited too if you download the book for
free it literally came out yesterday so
get your grubby little hands all over it
I mean your grubby little ear ethically
my ears I just remember that in q-tips
that's a different tension to track the
Dom iconoclast face your first audiobook
download for free once again without
comm slash grace for a free 30-day trial
and a free audiobook okay anyway it old
me with justice scummy hair you can
watch the full episodes with your eyes
on the full screen app if you have it
but then you can listen to all of them
on soundcloud an iTunes for free they
come out every Monday I forget to
mention that to you guys just in case
that's just a hey this is this is my
American Sign Language for announcement
reminder and it's not me
tickling your taint no no no no no I
listen to Taylor Swift's ready for it
I'm ready for I am filming this on the
day before Labor Day so it's a holiday
weekend so thank you to all of those of
you that labor particularly my mom your
labor made me I'm washing towels right
now whoa talk about pre-gaming for a
holiday weekend how are you okay let's
look on the internet for inspirational
conversation starters what's happening
in the world is the question I say
inside my head every morning when I wake
up and I am too afraid to really look
too deeply into it
Keanu Reeves is 53 does that change your
life today
oh just Trump is being awful okay
peaceful palm tree just fell onto the
ground in my backyard
if that isn't symbolism of how this
video is going at its best
and you guys are back in school now for
those of you that do school that must
suck are you having the suckiest time I
get it talk amongst yourselves I'm out
of that world now hey I'm a student of
life and guess what none of the lessons
dick doesn't even go in this year this
year is so dirty from not using q-tips
just bounce its directly off all the
earwax I can do music to you my birthday
is coming up so just slowly dip to end
towards the end halloween is coming up
what are you gonna be for Halloween let
me know in the comments down below let's
have a dialogue watch this So You Think
You Can Dance I've been watching a ton
of documentaries Asperger's r us if you
guys haven't seen that is so good it's
about these grown men with Asperger's
that live outside of Boston and they met
in a camp when they were younger and
their sketch comedy team and it
chronicles them putting together their
last sketch comedy show after being a
group for years and years because
they're all kind of going their separate
ways I can't recommend it enough okay
this is probably gonna be yeah
definitely gonna be where I cut off this
stream of consciousness video again um
confused on why you guys enjoy these
videos but really glad you do if you
like stream-of-consciousness
videos give this video a thumbs up so I
know to make more of them if this is
what you want and subscribe to this
youtube channel and click that little
ring bell notification because it'll
tell you when i make videos because
they tried to post Monday Wednesday and
Friday but we all know that that's not
always how it goes other than that I
don't know it's a tiny animal tap shoes
that was laying down for so long while I
set up and tried to find a place to
shoot this video and then as soon as the
camera started rolling
oops now I'm curious I'm gonna walk
around and get in the shot and still
focus